it is the first time, ladies and
gentlemen, that a plenary session in this
form has been convened at such short notice
this extraordinary measure is of
course also a reaction to an
extraordinary presidential case, namely
that a member state has decided to
withdraw from the community
i therefore very much welcome the
fact that the entire  the college of commissioners,
including lord hill, is here with us
today, and we
warmly welcome the president of the commission and the members of the commission to the house.
it is important that we, in the parliament of
european democracy, have a debate today on a
subject that touches us all
deeply, ladies
and gentlemen contrary to popular
comment in some bodies the
decision taken in the
uk is
a decision of the british people
but one that affects all citizens of
the european union
so it makes sense that the
a  parliamentarians of the peoples of
europe discussing this case here in this house today
let me
say one thing at the beginning of our debate
many
politicians and
in particular very many civil
servants from the united kingdom have worked in
the eu institutions for four decades, i
personally  like many of you, I have
worked together with colleagues from the
united kingdom for decades on the construction of
our house in europe,
so it is important to me, and i think i
speak on your behalf,
that we need all those
colleagues from the
united kingdom here in the house  and
above all to the many hundreds of
men and women in the political groups in
committees in the administration of this
house who have worked with us on the european
project on this day
say we deeply regret the
decision
that britain wants to leave us
but you colleagues  to
those who have worked with us here over the
years, we have a
deep
connection to them, both politically and personally, and his dear colleagues is clear,
the value of the
united kingdom for some in europe
's foreign policy but also in
the defense of its freedoms is
of the utmost importance,
however  the will of the majority of
citizens and northerners of the united
kingdom must also be activated and
respected, which is why we
certainly discussed intensively today the
question of article 50 and its
activation,
ladies and gentlemen, let
me thank one of the people in this room
difficult situations i
think has done a great job
and has also taken a great human
step lord hill has
given up
his office as commissioner of the united
kingdom as a consequence of his own attitude
so today will certainly be the last time with
us i would like to say out loud  hill
you campaigned for
the united kingdom to
remain i would like to thank you here on
behalf of parliament for this commitment
but for your work in the commission
at the same time
i am opposed
to this, dear colleagues, for this signal which also
shows which one  side the
overwhelming majority of
the parliamentarians of the european peoples are on the
side of those who
wanted to keep great britain in the european union
thank you we this strong signal at the same time
but also
lotte's look back is already a signal that de
facto the exit procedure has already
begun